Alight with bioluminescence as
they float through the night sky,
the firefly is a mystical, enchanting
creature for many cultures.
But not so for the West African Ewe
peoples of Ghana, Benin, Nigeria, and Togo.
For them, fireflies can cause great anxiety.
In Ewe mythology, fireflies may be the form
taken by an evil entity called the Adze.
While there are very few folk stories about
the ‘Adze’ as a physical monster, mostly
just passing references and descriptions,
‘adze’ as a belief is more complex.
So why has the idea of a flying,
nocturnal, blood-sucking firefly endured?
I'm Dr. Emily Zarka. And this is Monstrum.
A nebulous monstrous spirit, adze can take
on many guises, the firefly among them. The
Ewe peoples believe that this nocturnal force is
almost always ill-intentioned, and if called upon
through malevolent sorcery, may enter the body
and empower the sorcerer with special abilities.
While under the influence of malignant adze, these
individuals are called an adzetos or azetowos.
While possessed, the adzetos are compelled
into nocturnal shapeshifting. A floating ball
of light or a flame emerges from the possessed
person’s nose or mouth or may appear through the
top of their head. Often, the flame takes the
form of an owl, firefly, or a kind of beetle.
This allows the possessed to travel great
distances by flight, which comes in handy
because the spirit also compels the adzetos
to feed on the life force of other humans,
usually their blood or their flesh.
The word ‘adze’ however itself has a bit
of a complex etymology, especially amongst
west African people like Theon the mean
the Shante and so many others who live
in Togo, Benin, Ghana, and Nigeria.
That’s Helen Nde, researcher and
curator of Mythological Africans,
an online community that explores mythology
and folklore from the African continent.
In one context, as they are understood
as a creative genius and spiritual power,
especially as embodied and wielded by women,
Adzeis also understood as a bad sorcery,
so creativegenius and spiritual
power wielded for harm. Soto hurt
other people out of jealousy or envy, or
just sudden for design to see them suffer.
Helen taught me that all adze aren’t
bad ormalevolent. It's more about
the intention of the person who wields this force.
The capital “A” Adze monster we are talking about
is just one manifestation, a very frightening one.
The monster Adze’s ability to appear as an
insect makes it particularly threatening.
They could be anywhere and everywhere.
Their small size allows them to enter
seemingly closed spaces through keyholes,
cracks, and under door frames. And
insect-borne illness is already a threat.
In some variations of Adze lore, the
monsters have an appendage like an
elephant trunk or ant-eater -like nose used
to slurp up the blood of their victims.
If blood isn’t handy, the creatures will drink
palm oil, coconut water, or coconut milk,
so these fluids can be offered to appease
an Adze monster and protect one’s community.
Flying, nocturnal, blood-sucking
insects—you would think the mosquito
would be the most common form, so why fireflies?
If you start with the understanding of as a, as
a flame-like entity, which comes out of people's
noses and mouths or out the top of their heads and
flies around at night, looking for other people
to stop blood from and cause death or diseaseto
then it makes sense that the firefly would be one
of the creatures associated with this entity. It
flies around at night, it glows in the dark.
A flying insect that appears to glow like
a small flame makes sense. It’s also possible
that the belief in the monstrous Adze developed
as a response not only to illness more
broadly but to disease-carrying insects
like mosquitoes, which could explain the
proboscis-like appendage of the creature.
But let’s not forget, ‘adze’ mostly refers
to malevolent sorcery, not a monster.
The main misconception about that, I would
like to dispel is this understanding of it
as simply a blood sucking vampiric entity. Adze
cannot be understood outside of its context
as a manifestation of bad sorcery. So you have the
entity, but the entity comes out of the efforts of
a bad actor using occult powers. Um, blood sucking
is also just one of the ways in which they will
break havoc on a person's life. They also cause
illness and death. They cause mental distress
and they can cause loss of job, loss of property,
or just lots of good standing in society.
Ewe practitioners of this bad sorcery, in
general,may be associated with cannibalism and
consumption because they prey on the resources
of the community to the detriment of all.
Often associated with contentious familial
and community relationships, in Ewe culture
adze attacks pose a constant threat, most
predominantly to wealth andfertility.
And another valuable resource—blood.
The Adze monster’s preferred victims are children.
In fact, in some Ewe traditions, they
only hunt the most beautiful children.
My theory around this is that physical
attractiveness is, uh, an enviable quality.
And one of the motivating forces behind using
Adze is jealousy and envy and wanting other
people to suffer. So, uh, people who
have qualities that another person envy
become targets for Adze, and it's not just beauty.
There is intelligence and charisma and wealth,
and anything that a person might possess that
other people might, might, might want or feel
jealous towards them and want them to suffer for.
The Adze are active at night, and some people say
they see them in their dreams. If you manage to
catch one of these creatures, it will transform
into a human and attack you. So it’s possiblethat
they can be killed in this mortal form.
They believe, however, that if you were to catch
an Adzeand a transforming into a human being,
it will plead for its life and offer you all kinds
of things to make sure that you don't killit.
And if you spirits life, then it becomes your
friend and it doesn't bother you anymore.
There are groups within Ewe culture that
work against the use of malevolent sorcery,
neutralizing or punishing the
accused—sometimes with death.
Someone can be accused of being a blood-sucking,
possessed firefly or a traveling flame and also
look like a human during the day—and therefore
there’s a possibility that real innocent lives
can be taken in the name of Adze destruction.
Long a part of oral traditions, one of the Adze’s
first appearances in written literature
is in an ethnographic book written in
1906 by German missionary Jakob Spieth.
While his description isn’t incorrect,
he is very quick to label adze as
‘witchcraft,” a complicated term in Africa.
Over time, you know, with colonization
and the introduction of Christianity and,
and other spiritual belief systems. The
fear of Adze has only become more complex.
Now it is impossible to situate this outside
of the context of colonialism, because,
what happened with the wave of colonial enterprise
that swept across much of the African continent is
that traditional ways of organizing community
belief systems and political systems were
destabilized. And this had a profound effect
on the physical, emotional, and psychological
wellbeing of communities. And there is research
which shows that, where this, this destabilization
brought by colonialism, the inequities
and operations caused by that, that system
where they, where they happened, there is an
increase in complex beliefs, such as witchcraft.
Helen and I both found that identifying the
Adze as a vampiric spirit doesn’t occur until
the 20th century, in Matthew Bunson’s
1993 book The Vampire Encyclopedia.
So the Adze gained the “vampire” moniker not
from the culture from which it originated,
but from an attempt to contextualize theentity
to a broader, largely Western,audience.
It’s so important that we trace back to
and understand the origins of this monster.
Without that the true meaning is lost and muddled.
There is a resurgence in mythology and
folklore from the African continent,
which is good, but it also carries the risk
of misunderstanding and misinterpretation,
especially since many of the documented sources of
these mythologies and folklores that are available
were done by people who are not themselves
African. So, it is well known that myths and
folklore are not just stories. They are containers
of cultural beliefs and values and practices. And,
and so they are used to preserve and plum
to expand cultural knowledge and practices.
And I believe that myths and folk will offer a
great opportunity to learn what we have thought
about ourselves in the past and explore the
possibilities of who we can be in the future.
I couldn’t have said it better myself.Studying
monsters isn’t about what you think youknow
because of something you’ve seen or read,but
investigating what that creature means
to theculture in which it was created.
Before you go, our friends over onIt’s Lit are launching a podcast! Hostedby the amazing Princess Weekes,
It’s Lit:Unabridged features all your favorite literature
topics and thoughtful, funny conversations from
amazing authors. It’s basically like joining
the best book club ever, but without having to
actually read anything. Check out the It’s Lit
podcast in the link in the description below!